North Korea's leadership is putting on a
show and everyone is expected to be in
lockstep even the kids the seventh Party
Congress is likely to cement Kim
jong-un's grip on power analysts say a
new Central Committee will be appointed
and key loyalists will be given top
positions in the party it's a chance for
the 33 year old leader to present a
united front to his people and the world
we'd hoped to report on the economy in
the run up but our government minders
instead took us here Pyongyang's
children's palace for them this is all
proof that Kim jong-un is fulfilling his
promise to improve people's living
standards his signature policy is to do
that at the same time as developing
nuclear-armed missiles across town we
were driven to an old armory a reminder
of the Army's central and continuing
role in North Korean life we've been
taken to see some military history here
in Pyongyang this rifle apparently fired
by the founder of the DPRK Kim il-sung
even his wife and then later his son Kim
jong-il they all apparently hit bull's
eye three bullets right in the centre of
the targets down there at the bottom of
the range hitting economic targets will
be harder there are hopes the party will
enact reforms to formalize a nascent
market economy a new middle class has
sprung up in parts of Pyongyang but much
of the population remains poor and
malnourished sanctions against North
Korea at the toughest in 20 years
wheat commodity prices have hit what
little the country does export and the
government continues to rely on China
for aid most expect we'll have to wait
for the curtains to come down on this
piece of political pageantry before we
get a clearer insight into North Korea's
future
you